Buonasera, vi starete chiedendo che fine hanno fatto i video
del canale principale. Ebbene
lo studio nuovo
e lo sfondo nuovo non sono ancora finiti
per lo sfondo manca poco, per lo studio invece
non ci hanno ancora attaccato internet. Fastweb
VI AMO. E siccome ho avuto la brillante idea di
iniziare questo nuovo progetto dello studio con i nuovi
video a fine luglio, e siccome
poi c'è agosto, che è il
periodo in cui YouTube non se lo caga di pezza
nessuno, diciamo che ho fatto una cazzata
quindi le trasmissioni regolari riprenderanno
da settembre. E dove disponibile a
colori nel formato PAL. Durante tutto
il mese di agosto, ci saranno altri tipi di video,
video leggeri, o video perduti, insomma
video del ca-. Oppure di vostra volontà,
potreste andare a vedere altri canali. Però poi basta che non
venite a rompere i coglioni se fanno cagare
Anch'essi in formato PAL. Grazie mille e buona serata.